well if they broke mess with it a lot
officially it looks like no good deed
goes unpunished so after a solid first
season of The Walking Dead being hailed
as one of the hottest new shows on TV
what is a producer to do oh that's right
fire the entire writing staff hey thanks
for getting us all to season two guys
and you know the whole The Walking Dead
pilot episode had the largest audience
of any original series on AMC I mean
that was cool but I'll take it from here
so have fun thumbing through the want
ads during Christmas you know
losers of writers meanwhile the writers
are like you do remember that we can go
on strike and effectively TV right
now it's no secret that I really like
the Walking Dead and I've heard people
complain that no episodes been as good
as the pilot episode but that's kind of
like Dawn of the Dead or most things for
that matter like no scene in the movie
Dawn of the Dead zazz cools when she
goes outside and she sees her
neighborhood just going to hell
nothing in most things is as cool as the
introduction to that world
I always remember your first time
watching The Walking Dead sickos but I
mean The Walking Dead still cool I mean
guns zombies blood death unstable Hicks
everything entertainments made of So
Solid viewers critic praised in the
second season renewal of the show
results in the eradication of the entire
writing staff just like that might as
well cast mark wahlberg in an uncharted
movie at this point away and i guess the
big plans to give scripts to freelance
writers like let me shoot Peter Parker
was a freelance photographer and you got
the best pictures of spider-man so but
I'm not sure how that pertains to this
I'm not gonna lie like at all stupid now
I don't object to given freelance
writers their shot I'd done I mean crap
they might be awesome I'm just saying if
you've earned your way you should be
able to move on if you beat level 1 and
Mario you get to advance to level 2 and
so it is if a group of writers get a
show from season 1 to season 2 they
should be able to write for season 2
they've earned it can changing up
writers like this that worked out for
Heroes it really didn't so what do you
guys think of Frank Darabont's plan to
fire all the writers and pretty much
write to show himself with freelancers
smart dumb mildly up and what do
you think of the first season of the
show comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]